i'm never scared actor jay ellis is no
stranger to an airfield like this thanks
to his role in a certain summer
blockbuster he knows his way around an
airplane but usually he's going by
another name you got the the call name
payback i did it was given to you it was
and was curious if you were to choose
one
would it be the north star
or would it be a gopher it'd probably be
the north star i'm from minnesota wow
and gophers just sound kind of silly
well then there you go that's how it
actually works i am a u of m gopher so i
get it the one that you like the least
is the one you get
so you're a gopher so there we go how
did i end up here wearing a flight suit
with a rodent's name on it
somehow it is all tom cruise's fault
what the hell
good morning aviators
this past weekend his top gun maverick
became the sixth highest grossing film
in domestic box office history knocking
off the likes of titanic and avengers
infinity war and starting tomorrow it's
available for digital download at home
there's no going back right to celebrate
the film's co-star invited me along to a
friendly competition a little something
aviators call a dog fight any message
for gopher yeah
it's payback time
[Music]
i've never been this close to another
airplane
how do you feel about these mountain
ranges
i love them they're beautiful i think we
should get a little closer to them
i'm good
[Music]
i remember the first time tom told us
that we were gonna get in a jet and he
turns and looks at us and tells us like
you're gonna be in there every single
day you're gonna fly
hours a day and you're gonna be
a pilot and everyone's like man this
dude is crazy i am not doing that and
then you get up there and you fall in
love with it you truly fall in love with
it
are you ready for some dog fighting
jamie i guess stay back versus gopher
who's gonna win you're looking scared up
there come and get me
don't worry i'm coming i see you over
there i don't see you that's his trouble
fight's on fight's off left to left baby
i'm coming home
three two one you've got the controls
what i'm gonna want you to do is roll it
upside down to the left
upside down and pull back like that yep
oh my gosh
oh this feels so unnatural there you go
hold the trigger pull the trigger
hey playback with the first kill
i'll give you that one
all right you ready for round two yep
let's go get him oh
oh which way we're trying to go to the
right okay
come here jamie there they are come here
jamie oh can i get him can i get him
there he is it's just getting on her
tail bank right bank right now roll it
back to the right okay
and squeeze the trigger
we got him two's been hit
yeah so this is basically how we started
out
we learned like the basics of flight and
then once we got comfortable with that
we did a lot of bombing runs a lot of
low level runs and then pulling g's to
get out of there when did you stop being
nervous
about 30 seconds ago
all right it's time for the tower
breaker who wants the most
i think i can only do one more
that's all i need
is gonna be these two cats going at it
head to head
you guys are all crazy three two one you
got control go get her
uh-oh where is he oh he's on our six
four freak right sister launched right
through the clock
all right now pull the trigger pull the
trigger
i told you i only needed one more
as we came in for a landing it was time
for one final tradition that jay pulled
straight out of the film whoever gets
shot down first has to do 200 push-ups
guys
that's a lot of push-ups looks like we
got to do 200 push-ups now
i'm all about following tradition but
tom's right that is a lot of push-ups
64.
i really did about 5.
um i want to give a special shout out to
my amazing pilot kristoff narco weber
down at sky combat ace in san diego i
was scared the entire time you guys and
he kept me calm cool collected i got on
the ground people keep asking me did i
barf no nice how many g's did i pull
seven and a half almost eight all right
a lot of g's as a delightful piece well
done got the trash talk down i like it